now to John Kerry's testimony from 1971
before the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee I'm pretty much going to read
it as right
in one second thank you verify out I
believe
short notice
young
then the IKEA
well the committee come to order the
committee is continuing this morning
it's hearings on proposals relating to
the ending of the war in Southeast Asia
this morning the committee will hear
testimony from mr. John Kerry and if he
has an associates we'd be glad to hear
from them these are men who have fought
in this unfortunate war in Vietnam and I
believe they deserve to be heard and
listened to by the Congress and by the
officials in the executive branch and by
the public generally you have a
perspective that those in the government
who make our nation's policy do not
always have and I'm sure that your
testimony today will be helpful to the
committee in its consideration of the
proposals the Forrest I'd like to add
simply on my own account that I regret
very much the action of the Supreme
Court in denying the veterans the right
to use the mall
I regret that it seems to me to be but
another instance of an insensitivity of
our government to the tragic effects of
this war upon our people I I want also
to congratulate mr. Kerry you and your
associates upon the restraint in view
that you've shown certainly in the
hearing the other day when there were a
great many of your people here and I
think you've conducted yourself in the
most commendable manner throughout this
week which I'm sure whenever people
gather there's always a tendency for
some of the more emotional ones to two
things which are even against their own
interest but I think you had deserved
much of the credit as I understand you
were one of the one of the leaders of
this group and I have joined with some
of my colleagues specifically senator
Hart in an effort to try to correct the
change the attitude of our government
toward your efforts at expressing and
bringing to this committee end of the
country your views about the war and I
personally don't know of any group who
would have both a greater justification
for doing it and also a better more Act
review of the effect of the war which it
as you know there has grown up in this
town a feeling that it's extremely
difficult to get accurate information
about the war and I don't know a better
source than you and your associates so
we're very pleased to have you and your
associates mr. Carey and at the
beginning if you would give to the
reporter your full name and a little of
your short briefly your biographical
attitude forth so that the record will
show that clearly I would like to say
for the record that and also for the men
behind me who are also wearing the
form in their medals that my sitting up
here is really symbolic I'm not here as
John carry on here as one member of a
group of 1000 which is a small
representation of a very much larger
group of veterans in this country and
we're it possible for all of them to sit
at this table they would be here and
have the same kind of testimony I would
simply like to speak in very general
terms I apologize that my statement is
general because I received notification
yesterday you would hear me and I'm
afraid because of the injunction I was
up most of the night and haven't had a
great deal of chance to prepare I would
like to talk representing all those
veterans and say that several months ago
in Detroit we had an investigation at
which over 150 honorably discharged and
many very highly decorated veterans
testified to war crimes committed in
Southeast Asia not isolated incidents
but crimes committed on a day-to-day
basis with a full awareness of officers
at all levels of command it's impossible
to describe to you exactly what did
happen in Detroit the emotions in the
room the feelings of the men who were
reliving their experiences in Vietnam
but they did they relived the absolute
horror of what this country in a sense
made them do they told the stories of
times that they had personally raped cut
off ears cut off heads taped wires from
portable telephones to human genitals
and turned up the power cut off limbs
blown up bodies randomly shot at
civilians razed villages in the fashion
reminiscent of gingers Kahn shot cattle
and dogs for fun poisoned food stocks
and generally ravaged the countryside of
South Vietnam in addition to the normal
ravage of war and the normal and very
particular ravaging which is done by the
applied bombing power of this country we
called this investigation the Winter
Soldier investigation
the term Winter Soldier is a play on
words of Thomas Paine's in 1776 when he
spoke to some sunshine patriot and
summertime soldiers who deserted at
Valley Forge because the going was rough
and we have come here to Washington to
come here because we feel we have to be
winter soldiers now we could come back
to this country and we could be quiet we
could hold our silence we could not tell
what went on in Vietnam but we feel
because of what threatens this country
the fact that the crimes threatening not
Reds and not redcoats but the crimes
which were committing or what threaten
it and we have to speak out I would like
to talk to you a little bit about what
the result is of the feelings these men
carry with them after coming back to
from Vietnam the country doesn't know it
yet but it's created a monster
a monster in the form of millions of men
who have been taught to deal and to
trade and violence and who are given the
chance to die for the biggest nothing in
history men who have returned with a
sense of anger and a sense of betrayal
which no one is yet grasped as a veteran
and one who feels this anger I'd like to
talk about it we're angry because we
feel we have been used in the worst
fashion by the administration in this
country in 1970 at West Point vice
president Agnew said some glamorized the
criminal misfits of society while our
best men died in Asian rice paddies to
preserve the freedoms which those
misfits abused and this was used as a
rallying point for our effort in Vietnam
but for us his boys in Asia whom the
country was supposed to support his
statement is a terrible distortion from
which we can only draw a very deep sense
of revulsion and hence the anger of some
of
men were here in Washington today it's a
distortion because we in no way
considered ourselves the best men of
this country because those he calls
misfits were standing up for us in a way
that nobody else in this country dared
to because so many who have died would
have returned to this country to join
the misfits in their efforts to ask for
an immediate withdrawal from South
Vietnam because so many of those best
men have returned as quadriplegics and
amputees and they live forgotten and
veterans administration's hospitals in
this country which fly the flag which so
many have chosen as their own personal
symbol and we cannot consider ourselves
America's best men when we were ashamed
of and hated what we were called on to
do in Southeast Asia
in our opinion and from our experience
there is nothing in South Vietnam
nothing which could happen that Ria's
realistically threatens the United
States of America and to attempt to
justify the loss of one American life in
Vietnam Cambodia allows by linking such
loss to the preservation of freedom
which those misfits supposedly abused is
to us the height of criminal hypocrisy
and it's that kind of hypocrisy which we
feel is torn this country apart we are
probably much more angry than that and I
don't want to go in to the foreign
policy aspects because I'm outclassed
here I know that all of you have talked
about every possible every possible
alternative to getting out of Vietnam we
understand that we know that you've
considered the seriousness of the
aspects to the utmost level and I'm not
going to try and deal on that but I want
to relate to you the feeling which many
of the men have returned to this country
express because we are probably angriest
about all that we were told about
Vietnam and about the mystical war
against communism
we found that not only was it a civil
war
were an effort by a people who had for
years been seeking their liberation from
any colonial influence whatsoever but
also we found that the Vietnamese when
we had enthusiastically molded after our
own image were hard put to take up the
fight against the threat we were
supposedly saving them from we found
that most people didn't even know the
difference between communism and
democracy they only wanted to work in
rice paddies without helicopters
strafing them in bombs with napalm
burning their villages and tearing their
country apart they wanted everything to
do with the war particularly with this
foreign presence of the United States of
America to leave them alone in peace and
they practiced the art of survival by
siding with whichever military force was
present at a particular time be it get
kong north vietnamese or american we
found also that all too often american
men were dying in those rice paddies for
want of support from their allies we saw
firsthand how monies from american taxes
was used for a corrupt dictatorial
regime we saw that many people in this
country had a one-sided idea of who was
kept free by our flag as blacks provided
the highest percentage of casualties
we saw vietnam ravaged equally by
american bombs as well as by Search and
Destroy missions as well as by Vietcong
terrorism and yet we listened while this
country tried to blame all of the havoc
on the Vietcong we rationalized
destroying villages in order to save
them we saw America lose her sense of
morality as she accepted very coolly
emile i and refused to give up the image
of american soldiers that hand out
chocolate bars and chewing gum we
learned the meaning of free-fire zones
shoot anything that moves and we watched
while america placed a cheapness on the
lives of Orientals
we watched the united states
falsification of body counts in fact the
glorification of body counts
we listened while month after month we
were told the back of the enemy was
about to break
we fought using weapons against oriental
human beings with quotation marks around
that we fought using weapons against
those people which I do not believe this
country would dream of using we'll be
fighting in a European theater or let us
say a non third world people theater and
so we watched while men charged up hills
because a general said that Hill has to
be taken and after losing one platoon or
two platoons they marched away to leave
the hill for the reoccupation of the
North Vietnamese because because we
watched pride allow the most unimportant
of battles to be blown into
extravaganzas because we couldn't lose
and we couldn't retreat and because it
didn't matter how many American bodies
were lost to prove that point and so
they were hamburger Hills and caissons
and Hill 880 ones and firebase sixes and
so many others and now we're told that
the men who fought there must watch
quietly while American lives are lost so
that we can exercise the incredible
arrogance of Vietnam izing the
Vietnamese each day
making a very significant statement let
him proceed each day to facilitate the
process by which the United States
washes her hands of Vietnam someone has
to give up his life so that the United
States doesn't have to admit something
that the entire world already knows so
that we can't say that we've made a
mistake someone has to die so that
President Nixon won't be and these are
his words the first president to lose a
war and we are asking Americans to think
about that because how do you ask a man
to be the last man to die in Vietnam how
do you ask a man to be the last man to
die for a mistake but we're trying to do
that and we're doing it with thousands
of rationalizations and if you read
carefully the president's last speech to
the people of this country you can see
that he says and says clearly but the
issue gentlemen the issue is communism
and the question is whether or not we
will leave that country to the
Communists or whether or not we will try
to give it a hope to be a free people
but the point is they're not a free
people now under us they're not a free
people and we cannot fight communism all
over the world and I think we should
have learnt that lesson by now but the
problem of veterans goes beyond this
personal problem because you think about
a poster in this country with a picture
of Uncle Sam and the picture says I want
you and a young man comes out of high
school and says that's fine I'm going to
serve my country and he goes to Vietnam
and he shoots and he kills and he does
his job or maybe he doesn't kill maybe
he just goes and he comes back when he
gets back to this country he finds that
he isn't really wanted because the
largest unemployment figure in the
country it varies depending on who you
get it from the
administration 15% various other sources
22% but the largest figure of unemployed
in this country are veterans of this war
and of those veterans 33% of the
unemployed of black that means one out
of every ten of the nation's unemployed
is a veteran of Vietnam the hospitals
across the country won't or can't meet
their demands
it's not a question of not trying they
haven't got the appropriations a man
recently died after he had a tracheotomy
in California not because of the
operation but because there were not
enough personnel to clean the mucus out
of his tube and he suffocated to death
another young man just died in a New
York VA hospital the other day a friend
of mine was lying in a bed two beds away
and tried to help him but he couldn't
they rang a bell and there was no one
there to service that man and so he died
of convulsions 57%
I understand 57% of all those entering
VA hospitals talk about suicide some 27%
of tried and they tried because they
come back to this country and they have
to face what they did in Vietnam and
then they come back and find the
indifference of a country that doesn't
really care that doesn't really care
suddenly we're faced with a very
sickening situation in this country
because there's no moral indignation and
if there is it comes from people who are
almost exhausted by their past in Dignan
seas and I know that many of them are
sitting in front of me the country seems
to have lied lain down and accepted
something as serious as Laos just as we
calmly shrugged off the loss of 700,000
lives in Pakistan the so-called greatest
disaster of all times we are here as
veterans to say that we think we are in
the midst of the greatest disaster of
all times now because they are still
dying over there and not just Americans
Vietnamese and we are rationalizing
leaving that country
so that those people can go on killing
each other for years to come Americans
seem to have accepted the idea that the
war is winding down at least for
Americans and they have also allowed the
bodies which were once used by a
president for statistics to prove that
we were winning this war to be used as
evidence against a man who followed
orders and who interpreted those orders
no differently than hundreds of other
men in South Vietnam we veterans can
only look with amazement on the fact
that this country has not been able to
see that there's absolutely no
difference between a ground troop and a
helicopter crew and yet people have
accepted a differentiation fed them by
the administration no ground troops are
in Laos so it's all right to kill
notions by remote control but believe me
the helicopter crews fill the same body
bags and they wreak the same kind of
damage on the Vietnamese and Laos and
countryside as anyone else and the
president is talking about allowing that
to go on for many years to come and one
can only ask if we will really be
satisfied when the troops march into
Hanoi we are asking here in Washington
for some action action from the Congress
of the United States of America which
has the power to raise and maintain
armies and which by the Constitution
also has the power to declare war we've
come here not to the president because
we believe that this body can be
responsive to the will of the people and
we believe that the will of the people
says that we should be out of Vietnam
now we're here in Washington also to say
that the problem of this war
is not just a question of war and
diplomacy it's part and parcel of
everything that we are trying as human
beings to communicate to people in this
country the question of racism which is
rampant in the military and so many
other questions also the use of weapons
the hypocrisy in our taking umbrage in
the in the in the Geneva Convention
and using that as justification for a
continuation of this war when we argue
more guilty than any other body of
violations of those Geneva Conventions
in the use of free-fire zones harassment
interdiction Fire Search and Destroy
missions the bombings the torture of
prisoners the killing of prisoners
accepted policy by many units in South
Vietnam
that's what we're trying to say it's
part and parcel of everything an
American Indian friend of mine who lives
on the Indian nation of Alcatraz put it
to me very succinctly he told me how as
a boy on an Indian Reservation he had
watched television and he used to cheer
the Cowboys when they came in and shot
the Indians and then suddenly one day he
stopped in get Nam and he said my god
I'm doing to these people the very same
thing that was done to my people and he
stopped and that's what we're trying to
say that we think this thing has to end
we're also here to ask we are here to
ask and we're here to ask violently
where are the leaders of our country
where is the leadership we're here to
ask we're a McNamara vos tau Bundy
Kilpatrick and so many others where are
they now that we the men whom they sent
off to war have returned
these are commanders who have deserted
their troops and there is no more
serious crime in the law of war the Army
says they never leave their wounded the
Marines say they never leave even their
dead
these men have left all the casualties
and retreated behind a pious shield of
public rectitude they've left the real
stuff of their reputations bleaching
behind them in the Sun in this country
and finally this administration has done
us the ultimate dishonor they have
attempted to disown us and the
sacrifices we made for this country in
their blindness and fear they have tried
to deny that we are veterans
that we served in Nam we do not need
their testimony our own scars and stumps
of limbs our witness enough for others
and for ourselves we wish that a
merciful God could wipe away our own
memories of that service as easily as
this administration has wiped their
memories of us but all that they have
done and all that they can do by this
denial is to make more clear than ever
our own determination to undertake one
last mission to search out and destroy
the last vestige of this barbaric war to
pacify our own hearts to conquer the
hate and fear that have driven this
country these last ten years and more
and more and so in 30 years from now our
brothers go down the street without a
leg without an arm or a face and small
boys asked why we will be able to save
Vietnam and not mean a desert not a
filthy obscene memory but mean instead
the place where America finally turned
and where soldiers like us helped it in
the turning thank you
John Kerry at the time of former Navy
lieutenant made his comments before the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee on
April 22nd 1971 following his opening
remarks members of the committee
questioned mr. Kerry here are some of
those exchanges mr. Kerry it's quite
evident from that demonstration that
you're speaking not only for yourself
but for all your associates I would say
as you crop properly said in the
beginning you said that you wish to
communicate I can't imagine anyone
communicating more eloquently than you
did and I think it's extremely helpful
and beneficial to the committee into the
country to have you make such a
statement you said you'd been awake all
night I can see that you spent that time
very well indeed perhaps that was the
better part of it is better that you'd
be awake than otherwise are you have
said that as you know the question
before this committee and the Congress
is really how early in the war the
resolutions which we've been hearing
testimony about during the past several
days the sponsors of which are some
members of this committee are seeking
the most practical way that we can find
and I believe then to do it at their
earliest opportunity we can that's the
purpose of these hearings and that's why
you were brought here
you've been very eloquent about the
reasons as to why we should proceed as
quickly as possible are you familiar
with some of the proposals that are
before the committee and yes I am saying
you are familiar with in me I would well
you say for yourself you do support or
do you have any particular views about
any one of them
wish to give to the committee my feeling
senator is are undoubtedly this Congress
and I don't mean to sound pessimistic
but I do not believe that this Congress
will in fact end the war as we would
like to which is immediately and
unilaterally therefore if I were to
speak to any I would obviously say that
we must set a date and the date must be
the earliest possible date but I would
like to say in answering that that that
that I do not believe it is necessary to
stall any longer I've been to Paris I've
talked with both delegations to the
peace talks that is to say they were
Democratic Republic of Vietnam and the
provisional Revolutionary Government and
of all eight of Madame Binns points it
has been stated time and time again and
was stated by senator vance Harkey when
he returned from paris and has been
stated by many other officials of this
government that if the united states
were to set a date for withdrawal the
prisoners of war will be returned
I think this negates very clearly the
argument of the president that we have
to maintain a presence in Vietnam to use
as a negotiating block for the return of
those prisoners the setting of the date
will accomplish that as to the argument
concerning the the danger to our troops
were we to withdraw our state that we
would they have also said many times in
conjunction with that statement that all
of our troops the moment we set a date
will be given safe conduct out of South
Vietnam the only other important point
is that we allow the South Vietnamese
people to determine their own future and
that ostensibly is what we've been
fighting for anyway I would therefore
submit that that the the most expedient
means of getting out of South Vietnam
would be for the President of the United
States to declare a ceasefire to stop
this blind commitment to a dictatorial
regime
Tukey Kim regime accept a coalition
regime which would represent all the
political forces of the country which is
in fact what a representative government
is supposed to do and which is in fact
what this good government here in this
country purports to do and pull the
troops out without losing one more
American and still further without
losing the South Vietnamese van der
Symington thank you for chairman
you see Kerry move your microphone a
little bit will you
which way sir that way you have a Silver
Star if you're not yes I do and you have
a Purple Heart yes I do
how many clusters on it two clusters
you've been wounded three times yes sir
I have no further questions chairman
today Carrie
the Defense Department seems to feel
that if we set a definite date who
withdrawal when our forces got down to a
certain level they would be seriously
endangered by the North Vietnamese and
the big Kong do you believe that the
North Vietnamese would undertake to
prevent our withdrawal from the country
and attacked the remaining troops that
remain there
well senator if I may ask you directly I
believe that we're running that danger
with the present course of withdrawal
because the president has neglected to
state to this country exactly what his
response will be when we reach the point
that we do have let us say 50,000
support troops in South Korea I'm not
telling you what I think I'm telling you
what the department says yes sir I
understand you do only that your North
Vietnamese would seriously undertake to
impede OU with complete withdrawal I
know I do not believe that the North
Vietnamese would and that's been clearly
indicated at the Paris peace talks that
they would not you think they might help
carry the bags for us I I would say that
they would be more prone to do that than
the army of the South Vietnamese now
you're getting your answers ahead of my
question what time would like to know
now is if we as we complete our drawl
and say get down to ten twenty thirty or
even fifty thousand troops left there
would be any effort on the part of the
South Vietnamese government in your
opinion to impede or the South
Vietnamese army to impede their
withdrawal now I'd I don't so so I don't
see why North beat them
I don't think so for the simple reason
object but no I used to talk with
officers there about this we asked them
and one officer used it took great
pleasure in in playing with me in the
sense that he'd say well you know you
Americans you come over here for one
year and you can afford you know you go
to Hong Kong for our and our and if
you're a good boy you get another RNR or
something but but you know you can
afford to charge bunkers but I have to
try and be here for thirty years
and stay alive and I think that that
really is the governing principle by
which those people are now living and
have been allowed to live because of our
mistake so that when we in fact state
let us say that we will have a ceasefire
or have a coalition government most of
the two million men that you often hear
quoted underarms most of whom are
regional popular reconnaissance forces
which is to say a militia and a very
poor militia at that will simply lay
down their arms they haven't done so
already and not fight and I think you'll
find that they will respond to whatever
government evolves which answers their
needs and those needs quite simply are
to be fed to bury their dead in plots
with their ancestors live to be allowed
to extend their culture to try and
and exist as human beings and I think
that's what will happen I I can cite
many many instances sir when as in
combat when these men refuse to fight
with us when they shot with their guns
off in this area like this their heads
turned facing the other way when we were
taken under fire we Americans supposedly
fighting with them and pinned down in a
ditch and I was in the Navy and this was
pretty unconventional but when we were
pinned down in a ditch for covering
bodies or something and they'd refused
to come in to help this point-blank
refused I don't believe they want to
fight sir you think we are obligations
to furnish them with the extensive
economic assistance yes sir I think we
have a very definite obligation to make
extensive reparations to the people of
Indochina in one exchange of questions
Rhode Island senator Claiborne Pell
asked about Lieutenant William Calley
would you wouldn't you agree with me
though that what he did inheriting 20
men old men women and children into a
trench and then shooting them was a
little bit beyond the perimeter of what
even has been going on this war and that
that action should be discouraged there
are other actions not that extreme that
have gone on have been committed that if
we had not taken action of cognizance of
it that it would have been even worse it
would have indicated we encourage this
kind of action my feeling senator on
lieutenant Calley
is that that what he did quite obviously
is a horrible horrible horrible thing
and I have no bone to pick but the fact
that he was prosecuted
but I think that in this question you
have to separate guilt from
responsibility and I think clearly the
responsibility for what has happened
there lies elsewhere I think it lies
with the men who designed free-fire
zones I think it lies with the men who
encouraged body counts I think it lies
in large part with this country which
allows a young child before he reaches
the age of fourteen to see 12,000
violent deaths on television which
glorifies the John Wayne syndrome which
puts out fighting men comic books on the
stands which allows us in training to do
calisthenics to a four count on the
fourth count of which we stand up and
shout kill in unison which posters in
barracks in this country with a
crucified Vietnamese with blood on him
and underneath it it says kill the [ __ ]
and I think that clearly the
responsibility for all of this is what
has produced this horrible aberration
now I think that if you are going to try
lieutenant Calley then you must at the
same time if this country is going to
demand respect for the law you must at
the same time try all those other people
who have responsibility and any any
version that we might have to the
verdict as veterans is not to say that
Kali should be freed not to say that
he's innocent but to say that you can't
just take him alone and and that would
be my response to that but if we had I
agree with you the guilt is shared by
many many many of us including the
leaders of the get out school now but in
this regard if we had not tried him I
think would be much more criticized and
should be criticized I would think the
same faith will probably befall him as
if the fellows either sergeant or
lieutenant Schwartz in West Virginia who
is tied for life for very
the same offense and is without nine
months commuted and by the same token I
would hope the quality of mercy would be
exercised in this regard for a young man
who's not equipped for the job and ran
amok and that it would be exorcized
project that public opinion should think
this through and we have taken this
position finest held very much in a
minority I understand that senator but I
think it's a very difficult thing for
the public to think through faced with
the would be with the facts the fact
that that 18 other people indicted for
the very same crime were freed and the
fact that among those were generals and
colonels I mean this is simply not
justice that's all it's just not justice
I guess it's the old revolutionary added
you when you see the whites of their
eyes you're more guilty and this seems
to be our morality it has been pointed
out you drop a bomb from the plane you
don't see the whites of their eyes I
agree with you on this body count like a
Scottish no woman's saying how many
grounds for quarter the more the whole
concept would family wrong and those of
us who criticized it four or five years
ago we even more violently criticized
for criticizing thank you for being here
good luck and I hope you all are
successful john kerry testified for
nearly two hours before the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee this was the
scene at the conclusion of the hearing
as he informally greeted members of the
committee
you